Bladesmiths, today's competition
revolves around barbarians,
specifically the Goths
who sacked Rome in 410 A.D.
Along the way, the Goths seized
weapons of their adversaries
and incorporated them into
their own arsenals,
and today we're gonna ask you to
incorporate these weapons
into a billet from which
you will forge one of these.
A favorite of backstabbers
everywhere.
[suspenseful music playing]
A pugio dagger.
It is believed that the pugio
was the weapon used
by the senate conspirators
to assassinate Julius Caesar
on the Ides of March in 44 A.D.
Your challenge
in the first round
is to use a hada technique
to combine three or more
of these weapons
to forge a pugio.
Good luck, Bladesmiths.
Your three hours starts now.
For my stack, I wanna have
nine pieces or more
so that way, when you do
draw this out,
you wanna make more metal
than you need.
Having more is better
than not having enough.
[Alex] Right now, I've got
my billet welded up.
I've got six separate pieces
about four inches
by an inch wide.
Got it tacked up, heating up.
I've still got a few jitters
that I gotta work out,
but I think once I got
my billet set,
I'm gonna be rollin'.
Double-edged daggers
I have no problem with.
I've made 'em. But the challenge
of this weapon
is the weapon
has to be symmetrical.
You can't be off.
The judges will see that.
They will know that.
If your measurement's wrong,
you can go home.
Don't do your welds right,
I don't wanna go home.
I wanna be number one.
[Kevin] I start drawing
the billet out lengthwise.
I don't wanna push out
too much metal at one time.
I want to maintain
that thickness of the blade
because I know the judges
are brutal when they test.
Hot metal!
[bleep]! I don't know if I got
enough material.
[Alex] Every time you forge weld
there's a chance of failure.
So every time I forge weld,
I'm nervous.
My first forge weld
is just a nice, light tap
to make sure everything's set,
and then once I know
that weld is set, I can start
drawing this billet out.
[dramatic rock music playing]
[Mike]
When you're forge welding,
it's a repetitive process.
You have to heat, hammer,
heat, hammer,
so it becomes
one solid piece of metal.
And when you're forge welding,
it's hit as hard as you can
as fast as you can.
[Ben] Alex did manage to do a
period correct Caesar quench.
-Caesar quench?
-He stabbed that forge 23 times,
moving it in and out,
before he went to the oil.
[Alex] My knife's looking
pretty straight.
It sounds hard. Looks hard.
I'm feeling good.
This is what I got so far.
I'm gonna go
into the heat treat
and then do a little more
finish grinding.
Kevin just quenched his blade.
-[David] File testing it.
-[Doug] Yeah.
-That was quick.
-That was very fast.
You gotta be [bleep]
kidding me.
Half of it's heat-treated,
half of it's not.
That is bad news.
On the second heat treat,
I bring it up to cherry red.
I got the same problem again.
Kevin may be file checking
while it's still hot
and thinking it didn't get hard.
So going for another quench
and then another quench.
That makes sense.
[Kevin] I'm starting to feel
the pressure.
I know I gotta get
on that grinder
to start getting
this thing cleaned up.
-And the tip looks very hot.
-Yeah.
[Wil] Come on, dude.
[dramatic rock music playing]
[Kevin] Nope.
What the hell's going on?
Don't know what I'm doing wrong.
Oh, she's hard now.
Phew. I'm good.
The heat treat/quench
is what hardens your blade,
so when you're chopping
or cutting,
it'll keep its edge.
So I need it to be
fully hardened.
Perfect.
[Wil]
Five, four, three, two, one!
Shut down your machines!
Drop your tools!
Stop what you're doing!
This first round of
bladesmithing competition
is over!
Yeah, boys.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the strength test.
The old shield stab and chop.
To test the strength
and durability
of your edges
and points on your pugios,
as well as their
overall construction,
I'll be chopping and stabbing
mercilessly into theses shields.
I don't really care what happens
to the shields.
I want to see what happens
to your tip and your edges.
Alex, you're up first. Ready?
-Let's do it.
-All right.
[Alex] I'm super nervous
going into the testing.
I'm not sure how my tang
is gonna hold up
after I just rewelded it.
My tip is thin,
so I'm just really hoping
that it can hold up.
[dramatic music playing]
[tense music playing]
Well, Alex,
first things first...
you lost about a quarter inch
of your tip here.
I'm looking at the grain
in there and it's...
it's not as fine
as I'd like to see.
It's probably overheating
during the quenches.
That aside, you left some
sharp corners of the wood
where the wood contacts
the brass
and it took a little nibble
outta my thumb right here.
But, in total,
it's got a good classic
pugio shape
and your edge held up
really well.
-Kevin.
-Let's rock it, man.
[laughs] All right. Let's do it.
[Kevin] I'm a little anxious
to see how my knife's
gonna perform.
One of two things
are gonna happen.
Either that shield's gonna give
or my blade's gonna snap.
[dramatic music playing]
All right, Kevin.
First things first...
your tip came off.
This grain is bigger
than I like.
You also lost a piece
of your edge right here.
There's a nibble out of it.
We can go to your handle
construction here.
Don't call my baby ugly.
No, sir.
-[laughs]
-You were under a time crunch.
You chose a method of completing
this challenge
in a way that's usable
and wieldable.
-Well done.
-I'm down with it.
Mike, you're up next.
What're you thinking?
-Let's do it.
-All right.
[Mike] I haven't been nervous
until right now,
and I'm going crazy.
My competitors both
lost their tips.
If I can keep my tip, don't
think I'ma have any problems.
But this is outta my control.
This is in the judges' hands.
[dramatic music playing]
Mike, your blade
doesn't have medallions
on either side
of that handle,
and it is a critical feature
in a pugio.
Therefore, your blade
cannot be tested
or measured evenly and fairly
with your competitors',
and it doesn't make the cut.
You did a lot of hard work
here, my friend,
and it's an unfortunate
circumstance.
At this time, I have to ask you
to please leave the Forge.
Good job, guys.
-Good job, guys.
-[whispering] Mike...
[Mike] You're gonna
come to this competition,
make sure you pay attention
to the parameters.
It's very important.
The smallest detail
that you miss can get you off.
This was an amazing experience.
I truly believe that if I had
my weapon tested,
I woulda went through
to the finals.
What's next for me is go home,
probably make another pugio,
and I'ma send a picture
to the judges
and say, "This is what I made."